what is unique about the dating scene in
Dubai Dubai is not very representative
of the Middle East it's got a completely
different culture to like Muslim values
and culture in general the reason being
is it is a playground for The Rich And
Beautiful what happens is the richest
men in the world flock to Dubai it's got
amazing perks if you want to make a lot
of money and any City where there's rich
men there are beautiful women it really
separates the men from the boys both for
men and women so what happens is a woman
has to really feel like everybody's a
competition so if she hasn't worked on
anything besides her looks She's gonna
find it's a difficult place to meet
people because if you think you're the
prettiest girl in the room there'll be
another pretty girl so it's hard for her
to stand out and for the rich guy if he
leads with money he will learn that's
not enough for the women out here
because you know it's a hundred
millionaires you have to bring something
else to the table but the problem is the
culture and the environment is so
distracting it's difficult for
Partnerships to connect and last read on
time even though everybody's craving it